hey guys how's it going I'm so excited
to stay in my kitchen I've got Diana the
physics girl her channel is so awesome
oh thank you my it's so excited you're
here I'm so excited to be here I'm going
to use the for a very very long time so
really happy to make your kitchen with
the same just what I'm super excited
about because it says Cub well today
we're doing a bunch of science kids that
are made for children we're also gonna
be doing a video on her channel so I'll
put a link in the description to go
check that out and make sure you go
subscribe to her channel especially if
you guys like science science and
physics we are the physics girl yeah but
this is all kinds of science here yeah
even a little bit of tech this is super
exciting a gemstone dig kit yeah I used
to collect rocks when I was little I
used to collect rocks too I still do
like crystals you know like wow
cleansing my crystals in the moon I
don't know I don't know i yeah you
didn't you find out there's like a
little mallet oh this is gonna be so fun
is that a bracelet it's top bracelet in
here I hope so this is the warm up
because it's not really like this
science you need not to unbox anything I
feel like that one you want to give it
just a stab like right in there just you
know like how do you do it what's just
of it like from well not you want to get
in there like right there and ice
alright alright keep it really don't you
got this oh satisfying did you did you I
don't discovery well we're gonna get
diggin 20 real gems 20 yeah it's like a
big block of I don't know dirt give us a
hammer or anything I think that's this
like a chisel being a paleontologist
somewhat requires patience and care I
have neither of those will have care
patients we've got another one because I
always felt bad like when I had friends
over
have a machete this is what I expected
when I came digest you tell ya this they
already have sort of a little pattern so
do we kinda like try to dig where the
pattern I don't know I kind of just get
in there okay a little worried about you
counter oh you do a little bit of look
at this this is because we don't want to
hurt our gemstones although we could
just like chip away at this oh yes give
it a little Jam what kind of a hailey
ecologist are you gonna rock on see it
we must be delicate I see oh that's
amazing
two gemstone I think there's three three
I kick-out
why didn't the kid come with a machete I
don't know that's the real question like
a kid oh there's another one
I'm sorry okay I've got you I mean don't
taint the rocks look there first
excavation it's here now how do you get
them out do you think this one has a
hole in it already if we put this in
water it would all just melt away
probably would just I love science let's
try it oh my gosh do you think there's
something else we can put in here that
would make it vinegar
I'm totally on board with us trying
things it's a little diluted with the
water but we think tin can robot next
yeah because it's adorable and you get
to make a walking wobbling bug-eyed
robot look how cute he is it's so cute
do you think we need to have our own can
should I pop a little Kroy do people
still like Lacroix
I'm a fan do you want one they might be
multi did you think fire they might be
moldy I don't know I don't think that
for my english scientific experience I
don't think that happens the Lacroix
we've got a coconut Cheers
look Roy so the may be expired look
right mhm
Tony 18 okay
at the end of 2018 do you think we need
a battery it's like the goal of this is
to use a tin can just as the body of a
robot robot can give us instructions or
do we just show anger it out look at
these in here we need to screw it in
there drop the motor of that push it
into four pegs four pegs nice nice
the arms are now being attached I think
I'm making it worse by trying to help
you making a lot of progress is what I
want to know yes very I think they
decided to trim their hands but we're
gonna leave it just like that
I think the screwdriver saved with it it
really did
that's number one can robot 1.00
that's pretty good kid I feel like we're
missing something right here this is
teamwork teamwork makes the dream or I
mean this is my dream so I guess we turn
it on right now okay you ready for this
i I've never been more ready for I yeah
we can just turn his eye backwards there
we go I am this way perfect bye-bye if
you switch these wires oh yeah okay this
is not the way that it told us to do
it's not the way I told us to do it all
Wow all this success we're really
incredibly intelligent guy should give
this video a thumbs up as far as a
science kiss for eight years old plus go
we got it nailed get it
okay we even Maddy doesn't like it we
have done a lot of things we can work on
any assembly line you need this says
there's 25 experiments thank you how the
one goes oh that was an advanced move
it's got some ingredients yeah let's
show them it's got iron powder citric
acid I think this is going to be pretty
exciting see we have in here Thank You
gaga there's only one pair you can have
them this is for a child oh my gosh
altogether the options this is fine
beautiful this candle has the most
warnings I've ever seen the kid comments
of M&Ms so a lot of these require things
that I don't have which are in most
normal households most people would
probably have them so this magic potion
one looks easy I think yeah I have
cooking oil vinegar step one ask an
adult for help oh shoot can you help us
we need 35 milliliters of hot water and
10 milliliters of vinegar they gave us
food coloring did you give us M&Ms this
is shocking 40 milliliters of oil is
this the trick okay so you can see the
two layers of oil and water because they
have different densities if you had a
question is this what we did does this
do we do it
did we do it is this it I mean if you're
a kid and you're like whoa why don't
they mix you can see the layers of
liquid you're right it is cool but it
also says now add the oil with a plastic
spatula two spoons of sodium turbit or
sodium temperature do you know what that
is said it suits my sister I was made
slime yeah pronounce this type of
ingredients I'm calling it turbo turn
now we need one level a spoon of sodium
turbine diverse where's my sodium
character so it is your great
if you can't pronounce a ingredient you
can just say okay okay so we're not
misinterpret our interpreter and see
what happened in this particular case
that the territory is sodium bicarbonate
but that looks now looks cool to me can
you think about a good view of this
because this might truly be magic food
who knows what's gonna happen
are you ready we're learning you wanna
exit do i mix value okay so we making
slime I don't know is it truly magic no
it's science well it bubbled I mean cool
what if we had more I don't really yeah
okay
am i really sure what we're looking for
oh no oh geez Oh what did it here yeah
the sodium bicarbonate moves slowly in
the oil until reaching the vinegar here
it reacts with the acetic acid as a
vinegar giving off carbon dioxide it is
this gas that fix it effervescent
bubbles we as adults need to know this
and now we know we have accomplished a
lot today we did way more science than I
usually do on my channel if we should
break back the Dave did it get any
easier it didn't really know just smells
well I think that we might have gotten
most of our gemstones out I mean there's
still a lot of these little guys but
they're listicle II I'm probably not
gonna make a bracelet out of it I'm just
kind of like with the knife I'll just
get it in there this is so fun this is
my favorite like I shouldn't be digging
while you're digging with you I'm
gonna put the knife away I only bought
myself on the candle I didn't listen to
any of the warning
boy thank you so much and huge thank you
to Diana for coming over she brought all
of these incredible sets over for us to
try out today thank you so much for
doing them I've never liked even as a
kid who was interested in science I've
never done anything like this and I was
like I know the person who'd be able to
unbox with me and test everything out I
was the photo
honestly like these gemstones or so much
fun make me deaf we didn't do it the
proper way
no but we did it with machetes we didn't
know yeah when you decide to do laundry
and you have a cork in your pocket oh
and dryer just explode this is so much
fun make sure you guys go check out her
channel I'll put all the links in the
description below and this is incredible
I'm so excited to see what we do on your
channel I'm really excited for you I'm
terrified
[Music]